what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are nearing we're really kind
of at the end actually a ventus's run on
guardians of the galaxy at least before
all-new all-different marvel and I think
I'm gonna do is I'm going to put a black
vortex on hold for a little bit any will
do it next week or something like that
but I don't really consider to be like
an essential story it's there and it's
kind of interesting um but I didn't
really care for it too much but again
one of the other reasons why I want to
put it on the burner is because I kind
of want to focus on like the core
guardians of the galaxy stuff you know
essential reading if you will to kind of
give people an idea of what was going on
with the guardians and how to get
current because we've still got you know
all-new all-different guardians of the
galaxy having said that after this I
think for the next couple days maybe for
the next day or so we're going to kind
of back off guardians for a little bit I
don't want to like hammer you guys with
too much Guardian stuff and so we'll do
like the origin of ego the Living Planet
and we'll probably do like the origin of
groove maybe you know some other stories
here there something like that but the
fact remains here this story is
basically called through the
looking-glass
this is really kind of like the tail end
of the Bendis run but funnily enough
this actually comes out of a comic
called guardians of the galaxy tema
and we've never really done guardians of
the galaxy Cosima but I've never
actually read it on with the exception
of the story that kind of came before
this one just because I want to have
some context but from what I understand
going into the galaxy team-up is exactly
what it sounds like it's just the
guardians of the galaxy teaming up with
different people I think there's a
guardians of the galaxy team-up story
with Deadpool
I'm not a horse I'm sure and if there is
I really want to cover that it was a
it's kind of a funny situation but the
fact remains here that what this does is
it basically kind of comes as the
fallout to the whole idea of Peter quill
being you know basically being elected
to the ruler of spark acts and it's kind
of a crazy situation because again for
the most part he didn't know that was
happening now a little bit of exposition
here a lot of explanation with the
blackboard X story that was basically
kind of like bindas co-op seen the
concept of the siege perilous and
historically speaking in Marvel Comics
the siege perilous was basically just an
artifact that people could pass through
and it would allow them to basically
start their lives over with everybody
not knowing who they really were
essentially having new identities that
kind of a thing it was effectively a
reboot device in the realm of you know
the Marvel landscape um but what the
black vortex was it was racially this
artifact that was given to a group
called the Viscardi I think it was or
the the Viscardi um and it was
essentially just this mirror that they
would look into and he would elevate
their powers to cosmic levels if they
submitted themselves to the
to blackboard X so in the case of like
kitty pryde for example under normal
circumstances she can pass through solid
objects but when she went through there
I guess when she submitted herself to
the to the blackboard X she could like
move objects through other objects on a
universal scale so she was she was just
wildly powerful in terms of her
abilities but the fact remains a lot of
this comes out of the end of that so in
truth once blackboard X concluded really
the only people who kept you know their
extreme powers or Gomorrah and Angel
which of course is why if you're reading
all-new all-different marvel right now
angel basically has these insane amount
of powers you know like like fiery wings
of different things like that is because
he maintained his connection or
maintained his powers from the black
vortex now the other half of this was
that black vortex dealt with a villain
named mr. knife and mr. knife was
basically the deposed Emperor of Spartak
Jason and so because of that eventually
led to the defeat of Jason that kind of
thing but with him effectively removed
from the equation and Peter quill having
been elected to president but elected to
Emperor sparked acts as we had talked
about in the last video the return of
Kitty Pryde and Peter quill and these
guys to his home planet has basically
been met with the arrival of Peter and
everybody learning that he's now
president he's now Emperor and so again
it's kind of crazy that this happens you
know and of course he's you know kind of
picking up on this and giving it you
know letting Kitty probably know hey
look it's not like I had a choice in the
matter
they basically just said that I'm going
to be elected now the other half of this
is that we get some weird alien thing
like some alien chick and she just like
pukes everywhere and then just as like
barf wonk and then just passes out and I
have no idea what that is like I'm gonna
look at his I don't know if like what
came out of her if it's like a baby
unloaded what came out of her is just
like like her just puking if it was
something that she ate like I have no
clue what it is
but regardless she's definitely having a
very bad day so because of this because
of the fact that Peter quill has been
elected to Emperor of Spartak this is
when the politics begin to come into
play right in a sense that as president
whether he chose to be or not he is now
president which means that he is going
to be apprehended by the Royal Guard and
taken back to Spartak now in a lot of
ways Brian Michael Bendis is drawing on
like real world concepts right like for
example the President of the United
States when it comes to the Secret
Service when a person is part of the
Secret Service detail that deals with
the president because a majority of the
Secret Service deals with like
counterfeiting on different
like that but for the section of the
Secret Service that deals with the
president keeping the president alive is
their number one concern they will seize
the president and they will carry him
out of a room if it means that the
president is going to be kept alive say
for example there was an impending
attack in Washington DC or if the
president refused to leave the Secret
Service would drag him they would pick
him up by his arms and legs and carry
him out of that room and taken to a
bunker because the role of the president
is not designed for the further wishes
and wants of the person who's in that
office the world the president has a
much higher responsibility to the
country and so because of that the
Secret Service is designed to make sure
the president lives much like this the
the Royal Guard and smart acts are there
to make sure that Peter quill gets back
to spartax and fulfills his role as
president now the question has to be
asked here well what if he just like
took off to the furthest reaches of
space they would find him they would
follow him and they would find him and
they would bring him back now this is
kind of an interesting situation because
it's basically been disbanded heap in
mind that you know in the days are
really in the stories leading up to two
black vortex Kitty Pryde hit basically
left earth and traveled over to find
Peter quill which led to her becoming
part of blackboard X and the two of them
actually being together as a couple the
problem with this is that in her mind
when she and Peter were together he was
just kind of like a rogue you're just
going like a scoundrel out there doing
his own thing was no real regard for how
it affected people but she was like the
one great thing in his life that he
cared about so it was like the good girl
dating the bad boy which we always know
usually ends in disaster was to grow up
and so because of that much like that
whole dichotomy Peter and Kitty are
running into problems because now Peter
basically has to step into the role of
being a responsible human despite not
being ready for now initially where he's
kind of apprehensive about it where he's
just kind of ready to run away when he
actually is when he arrives back of
spartax he's met with just crowds and
crowds of people who were there cheering
his name now this does not mean that
Peter suddenly like yeah you know
Quailman like it's not suddenly all
hyped up you know and all you know all
high on himself instead it's really more
terrifying now than it ever was before
and the reason why is because of the
fact that it's one thing for him to be
told people out there are counting on
you because now they're nameless
faceless people they can never see they
didn't know anything about but when he's
looking at them and he's looking at like
the desperation on their faces well
suddenly it makes them real
makes them tangible it makes their
desperation and their lack of great
circumstances it makes their desire for
a better life something that he can look
at and he can see it creates a more
tangible situation and so where he's
initially reluctant where he of India
initially says no ultimately his backs
against the wall and he's forced to say
yes not for kitty pryde this is a very
imposing situation because where she
initially greets the idea of like very
lavish accommodations and everything's
like that in the end she is still
someone who very much comes from humble
means and so because of that for her to
suddenly be met with these huge lavish
conditions and things like that's being
treated like a queen and so on and so
forth it's a little more than she could
handle now keep in mind I mean she was
part of the Xavier Institute she was
part of like the super technologically
advanced stuff that Xavier had but in
the confines of what it meant to Train
x-men but all in all she's not used to
being treated like you know what as a
member of the highest royalty it's not
really something she's comfortable with
and it's cool to see because it grounds
her character you know it makes her
someone where it's like look she's kind
of like the girl next door in a lot of
ways and so because of that we get this
little segment of these different people
in terms of how they're acclimating to
these conditions now Rocket Raccoon has
no problem acclimating to the conditions
that he's being given he's getting he's
getting a bath and it looks amazing like
he's having the time of his life he's uh
he's definitely enjoying himself Groot
isn't this very lavish for some you know
kind of getting back into roots with
himself as a floor philosophy and then
of course you have Drax who's training
the Royal Guard and really he's not
really training him so much is just
beating the hell out of him so it's kind
of cool to see this whole thing
unfolding but in the midst of all this
you know where Peter quill is again kind
of ready to walk away where he's not
really sure it's something he can handle
we basically have the return of tendon
now this is what I say this kind of
comes out of Guardians came up and the
reason why is because Marvel was always
kind of poking around with the character
of Gamora and she's always really
interesting I would feel like Gamora was
a character who really kind of deserved
her time in the Sun and she got it to a
degree but only insofar that she was
like a tack on to somebody else's story
which is why I love the more right now
in Marvel now 2.0 oh really I guess
all-new all-different marvel is because
we get to see a lot of her character and
how she deals with things but again as
we had talked about before with the role
of Gamora the biggest struggle she
always had was that the legacy of her
father always followed her and
a lot of people if Thanos was raising
worlds and conquering civilizations and
gomorrah was around there was in the to
go hand in hand for the one-two punch of
despots in the universe and so because
of that people looked at danos and it
looks like a more and said they share
similar identities now as we know the
more had basically defected from her
father right I mean she had walked away
from Thanos said look I don't want to
have anything to do with this life you
leave that advise you lead I don't want
to have any part of this alright this is
you you go do you I will go do me and
we'll call it a day and for the most
part she was kind of allowed to but
Marvel did this for the purpose of
giving her character a complex situation
because everywhere she went
there was a legacy of Thanos and so even
if it wasn't bounty hunters tracking her
down and handing her over to other
people it was individuals out there who
had been wronged by Santos whose
civilization have been pushed to the
brink of extinction by sales and all
they wanted was revenge and if they
couldn't kill Thanos they could kill
Gamora so it was constantly following
her around constantly tracking her down
and this is a guy by the name of kinder
who basically does this exact same thing
he's the guy whose planet was basically
raised by Thanos and Gamora was there
along for the ride so because of this in
guardians team-up the two initially
encountered one another and we basically
got that little bit of a story that has
gave me a second ago when they just kind
of fought one another a little bit and
Kendon story was revealed it's not the
most significant story ever but
following his initial defeat he had
basically got you know gathered a force
of the Chitauri and then brought them in
for the purpose of attacking Spartak and
obliterating the entire planet now this
is one of the things a lot of people do
when it comes to conflicts in Marvel
Comics it usually goes one of two ways
either they can defeat the person
head-on or they can in run that person
and they can basically tear down
everything that person knows and loves
when it comes to Gamora despite all the
different conflicts that she's been in
her loyalties are to the guardians of
the galaxy despite how the Elda bravado
that she puts off the kind of you know
flow I want to be left alone and I don't
care about anything
she's very devil-may-care in the sense
that she cares about the guardians of
the galaxy she cares about the friends
and family that she has she cares about
the lives of the people that are part of
her life and so when she looks at the
planet of Spartak she looks and says
look you know you have this guy Kenan
showing up here raising the world but
this is the home of Peter quill this is
the home of a friend of mine there are
needless innocent people here who are
being destroyed in this onslaught Gamora
has to step on do
this is really her fight and that's one
of the things that I liked about this so
much is that it's gamora's battle it's
not the Guardians battle it's gomorrah's
battle and so while the Guardians are
just kind of out there facing off
against the other dattari well you know
agent Venom's there with them and so on
and so forth Gamora take skinned and
head-on now the battle between the two
of them is actually kind of interesting
it's pretty short-lived in the mind of
Kim nummy sees her agent of Cesar is
okay well luckily this is the Gamora did
I met before they got more that I came
into conflict with before what he didn't
know was the events of black vortex and
so her power is on a universal scale now
I mean she's able to conjure swords of
pure energy I mean she's you know a
universal beam and so because of that
the fight between them is quick I mean
it is not long at all and he's
overpowered insanely fast minutes guys
start unloading on her taking her down
she immediately comes back up and says
look I'm going to give you an offer
either you can leave here with your life
and you can live another day and live
out whatever existence you have or you
can stay here and die but the other half
of this and that's what's so cool about
this is Gamora is giving him advice for
her own perspective for years and years
and years and years and years gamora's
character traveled around the Marvel
landscape holding on to her heat she
hated panas she hated everything he
stood for and that's what guide is room
that's what made her life the problem is
that all she found was death and
destruction in her wake
and all she found was death and
destruction waiting for her in the
future the guardians of the galaxy
offered redemption for her character
they offered the ability for her to
become as close as she can be to a good
guy to fight a noble cause to fight on
behalf of those who couldn't stand up
for themselves and it was a warming idea
it was a welcoming idea for Gamora she
put up a fight she'd put on the bravado
if she doesn't care you know she talked
down the people she'd be arrogant that
kind of thing but at the end of the day
she cared she cared about fighting for
the good guys and so what she does is
basically communicate this message to
him saying look all that guides you
right now is your head is your anger let
that go and go and live a life
everything you know is gone your world
is destroyed you know it's gone the
people that you knew it does they're no
longer part of the equation they're not
there anymore now you can hold on to the
ghost of your past and you can be guided
by your anger and death or you can just
let them move on you can move on except
the past is the past and start living
your life and so ultimately you know
where he says no and his forces are
totally
obliterated by gomorrah he ends up just
kind of backing off he ends up basically
just kind of leaving and walking away
but again you know this is really kind
of wraps us up because the more
effectively departs she takes off now
again this was ventus setting the stage
for you know the all-new all-different
marvel guardians of the galaxy the idea
that gomorrah was going to get her own
story you know the idea that she was
busy gonna be parted away from the
Guardians but it was also setting the
stage for Secret Wars so again following
this we jump directly into the main
Secret Wars line of stories itself so I
guess you could call this kind of
something similar to the last days of
the guardians of the galaxy
you know I guess but but the fact
remains here this kind of segue directly
into industry wars the problem with this
is that we really kind of end this with
with Kitty Pryde and Peter quill Thank
You deepraj saying look no matter what
will happen I'm always going to be in
your corner I'm always going to keep you
safe here oh we're actually going to
find out that things don't turn out that
way and that instead they actually end
up parting ways the issue of why that
happens is kind of explained half hag
you know haphazardly in the center
that's going to boot strapped in and
it's kind of given to us over the course
of like a an issue or something like
that because there's eight months
between the end of Secret Wars and the
start of all-new all-different marvel so
we don't know what took place between
those eight months and given the fact
that were year out we probably never
will which is kind of disappointing but
if you guys are new here to come in to
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and in the next video that
we do on guardians of the galaxy we will
pick up with all-new all-different
marvel so emperor quill and that kind of
stuff we will cover all that good stuff
and yeah I will catch you guys on it
peace
[Music]
[Applause]